c'est la deuxième photo spectaculaire
d'un trou noir qu'on nous révèle mais
cette fois ci le monstre n'est pas dans
une galaxie très éloigné nous met
directement au coeur de la voie lactée
c'est
le trou noir a un nom c'est jetèrent à
et c'est définitivement le grand patron
de la voie lactée et ses quelque 200
milliards des toiles c'est véritablement
le trou noir supermassif central d'une
galaxie qui gouverne un peu la dynamique
générale c'est un peu comme dans le
système solaire c'est notre soleil qui
décide n'est ce pas chacune des planètes
a son rôle à jouer mais c'est
majoritaire mal de soleil s'agit des uns
se trouve à 27 mille années lumière de
la terre c'est un objet énorme 4
millions de fois plus massif que le
soleil la non et camp des saints qui
orbitent autour de lui c'est de la
matière des gaz est désastreux qui se
consume avant qu'il ne les avale tout
rond mais contrairement à l'idée qu'on
pourrait en faire s'est jetée à est plus
un géant endormi qu'un fauve affamé il
ya des trous noirs qui sont très
gourmands a qui vont engloutir
énormément matters parce que à ce moment
là il se trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
matière proche de celui au centre de
notre galaxie présentement il n'a pas
beaucoup de matière proche de lui donc
il ne peut pas à engloutir beaucoup on
dit souvent qu'il est à jeun derrière
l'image révélé aujourd'hui se trouve une
équipe de 300 personnes une dizaine de
grands télescopes interconnecté sur la
planète l'assemblage de milliers de
photos différentes et une quantité
astronomique de données si on regarde
les images on a l'impression que c'est
un peu flou mais il faut garder en tête
que c'est une image agrandie d'une
petite région d'une galaxie qui
correspond à l'équivalent de voir une
balle de tennis sur la lune donc ce
qu'on veut voir si les coutures la balle
de tennis finalement l'étude de ces
juges des rares va permettre de mieux
comprendre l'origine de notre galaxie et
sa dynamique depuis sa formation il dix
milliards d'années dans le futur les
chercheurs vont également tenter de
repérer certaines des très nombreux
trous noirs plus petits qui perd ce
notre galaxie comme un fromage gruyère
ces petits trous noirs là a selon nos
calculs il y en aurait beaucoup dans la
voile est dans la voie lactée il y en
aurait à peu près 100 millions à de
petits trous noirs qui serait vraiment
distribué partout dans la galaxie donc
c'est quand même comme un des trous
noirs sont considérés comme un des
endroits les plus violents de l'univers
leur densité est telle que l aspect même
la lumière ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal